hey guys it's me jasmine katie and i
were recently at disneyland eating a
bunch of food
thinking about food as we do and then
she turned to me and was like what if
the rice were food
and i laughed because it was silly and
funny but then i thought let's do it
she's always challenging me
and so i'm going to challenge her let's
do this i'm so
scared i'm never talking to you about
anything
ever again jasmine how do we get into
this how does this happen to me
i am going to make the matterhorn
into a dessert the matterhorn is a ride
based off the actual mountain that's in
the alps if you're on a bobsled ride
where you're going through the dark a
crazy yeti is trying to kill you
it's super fun and it's the only roller
coaster i don't throw up on i
am going to make a croquembouche that
looks like a matterhorn and if you don't
know what a croquembouche is
it's a french dessert that is like a
cream puff tower i've never made
croquetboosh before it needs to have a
waterfall because there's one at the
disney ride
there's not gonna be a ride going around
or a yeti inside no yeti inside no yeti
inside no yeti inside stop making me
sick
the yeti is so important to matterhorn
first thing i have to do is actually
make the custard that's gonna fill
inside the cream puffs just get into it
i'm gonna heat up some whole milk we
need a ton of filling because we have a
ton of cream puffs that are gonna go on
this
we're gonna bring this up to just a
slight boil just as soon as it boils
we're gonna turn it off i'm just gonna
add some vanilla bean paste
about two teaspoons so i have 18 egg
yolks and we're gonna add in sugar
whip this till it's fluffy and pale and
it's gonna take about two minutes
i chose the matterhorn because it's my
favorite right at this time and i
actually do get kind of scared
cause it gets so dark when you go inside
the mountain although he's loud the roar
you know what i mean
the the one that's not gonna be in the
one that's not gonna be
in my my dessert now we're gonna add in
some cornstarch
our eggs are ready our milk is ready i'm
gonna turn the heat off
and we are gonna slowly add the milk in
so we don't cook our eggs which is
called tempering otherwise you're gonna
have some scrambled eggs in your custard
this is just gonna bring the eggs and
sugar
up to the same temperature as the milk
but gradually now we'll put this back
into the pot we'll turn our heat back up
and we're gonna
whisk this constantly you gotta do it
for about seven to ten minutes
it is really cool how all of a sudden
it's super liquidy and then it's just
this
yellow thick yummy goodness you
definitely start to feel some resistance
as you are
pulling the whisk through we got bubbles
we are good to turn the heat off i'm
gonna remove it from the heat
and at the end we're just gonna add
butter stir that in
finally we're just gonna put this
through a strainer to make sure
we have super super smooth custard once
all of that
is in we're just going to put some
plastic wrap right over so we're just
going to put it all the way
down on top of the custard so we don't
get a skin over it
this guy's done we're going to chill him
for about two hours in the fridge
so now we're going to make our choux
pastry which is just our cream puffs i'm
gonna combine some water
butter lots of butter sugar and some
salt we're gonna melt our butter and
bring this up to a boil our water
butter mixture is boiling so i'm gonna
add in my flour and turn off the heat
with a wooden spoon i'm gonna quickly
mix this up once
your mixture is thickened up and pulling
away from the bottom of the pan
we're gonna put it in a stand mixer and
then we'll slowly one egg at a time
incorporate our eggs i'll let it cool
slightly then transfer to a piping bag
and pipe some cream pumps
so i've greased a pan and i've put some
parchment down this is just to keep the
parchment in place
we're gonna do about one inch cream
puffs
so we have these little pointed tops do
not worry about them we're just gonna
dip our finger in some water
and then pat down last so they get nice
and golden brown and shiny
we're gonna add some egg wash i'm gonna
put these in the oven at 400 degrees for
15 minutes then i'm going to reduce the
temperature
to 350 for another 15 minutes do not
whatever you do open the oven if you do
this at home because it will deflate
your cream puffs you want cream
puffs not cream flats our cream puffs
are out of the oven now we'll fill our
cream puffs we're gonna
take it put the piping tip inside and
then just
gently squeeze your filling try not to
overfill them
and we'll just keep repeating that
process like a million times
if you're having trouble putting your
piping dip into your cream puff you can
always poke holes ahead of time with
like a steak
you can take a skewer and make holes
ahead of time so i'm just gonna fill the
rest of my cream puffs until they're all
done
and then next comes the tricky part so
now i'm going to make a waterfall out of
sugar i've definitely worked with sugar
before but i have never
worked with it to like manipulate it to
curve so we're going to see what happens
first i'm going to combine sugar
water and some corn syrup you don't want
to stir it while it's heating up because
otherwise
it'll crystallize and you'll have these
like big clumps but at the beginning
just so that everything gets
incorporated i like to stir it
i'm going to let this keep going until
it gets up to 300 310 that's at the
heart crack phase
and then i will add in sky blue food
coloring
to get that water that blue waterfall so
you're telling me
you're gonna make a waterfall but no
yeti
sugar is scary because it burns jasmine
i am gonna turn this off remove this
from the heat
so to make the waterfall i got a
silicone mat and i'm gonna try to run it
down
just do a little at first oh that looks
that looks cool
set this off to the side so right now
i'm taking the sugar and i'm doing what
they call
spinning sugar and i'm just throwing him
making a mess kill he's like
yeah that's right that's right it's very
like cobwebby
okay i think we're good let's move on to
like assembling this whole bad boy
together
it is time to make this croquembouche i
am definitely not going to be able to do
the traditional way
which is you build up these cream puffs
using sugar and there's no no structure
that they're built on they just build up
on themselves so i found this cone at a
craft store i've wrapped it in parchment
paper
and instead of using sugar to adhere the
cream puffs i am gonna use
melted white chocolate so i'm gonna take
a cream puff
and i'll just dip it in the chocolate
and apply it
to the base i'm gonna keep doing this
the things i do for you jasmine
thank you i'm feeling good i'm starting
to feel nervous as it's all getting
compacted
like just a little bit but i think my
chocolate's setting a little faster
which is making me feel a little better
do you think you have enough cream puffs
i i
think so it's a lot of cream i chose the
matterhorn because it's really one of my
favorite rides
you know what i like if you go on that
ride when it's nighttime like nine
o'clock when they're just about to do
the fireworks and the fireworks will be
happening
all around it and like you sometimes pop
out of the mountain and just be like
[Music]
that's the theme to jurassic park
sometimes tinkerbell used to come down
from the top of the matterhorn and one
time i was on the matterhorn and it was
so magical i was like
firework and then tinkerbell was just
like dude and i was like
it was like it was the happiest place on
earth this is not an ad for disney they
did not
sponsor this i'm gonna put the top on
and then maybe do
some around it oh my goodness
to finish this guy off we're not done
i'm gonna add some more cream puffs to
build out the sides and get more of a
mountain shape
then i'm gonna add shredded coconut that
i've dyed with different shades of green
food coloring
i'm gonna make little croquembouche
trees with a roseberry
to add the snow just like they have on
the matterhorn i'm going to dust some
powdered sugar
all over the top and finally i'll place
the waterfall onto the croquembouche
oh gosh oh my gosh it worked
i cannot believe that i did this i think
i nailed it i'm glad i did the chocolate
hack
i love the dusting of snow and the
rosemary smells so fresh
and it really reminds me of real trees
the waterfall has so much movement i
love the coconut grass i also think
my sponge sugar just gives that
waterfall even more motion
i'm so proud of this i didn't think i
was gonna be able to do this i hope they
think it looks like the matterhorn
let's see what they think of it and also
let's see if it tastes any good
you're ready to try coming in
she didn't make a yeti so i am yeti
you look like lilo and stick it's
beautiful katie
this is incredible it's like what you
would find in like a gourmet pastry shop
and i know you were joking about it when
we were at disneyland but
you did it air cheers so
good this is so good
thanks guys thank you guys for watching
i am definitely not going to do this
again because it was super stressful
unless you asked her
in the comments uh let us know and
jasmine this is fun but like
[Laughter]
nope
we are all adults
[Music]